a sound that is likely to ripple through
the nearly three trillion dollar company
that is apple able to beat back a move
to unionize a store in atlanta but now
defeated in maryland i want to give a
huge huge
a huge shout out to atlanta
because they prepared us for a lot of
this stuff that they were gonna do
so that helped us a lot by a nearly two
to one margin workers at the apple store
in towson maryland voted to unionize the
first apple store to take that step in
may these workers sent a letter to apple
ceo tim cook saying they had the support
from a solid majority adding they wanted
more rights to information and
collective bargaining we're literally
the face of apple how is it fair that we
are being dictated as to what to do what
to say how to act but we don't get any
say in any of the things that are
happening in our everyday lives
apple has yet to publicly respond but
they did recently raise hourly wages
from 20 dollars to 22.
this is just the latest massive company
to see its workers move to unionize one
amazon warehouse in new york did the
same recently
after employees from a starbucks in
buffalo voted to unionize more than 150
of the company-owned stores have now
voted to follow suit given the tight
labor market analysts expect this to
continue a labor shortage
workers are emboldened as a general
proposition
and also because of the
consequences the fallout so to speak of
the
pandemic these maryland workers sent a
message to try and make sure that
happens don't be scared
because it's scary
and that's okay
but don't be realize that if we can do
it you can do it
but this is just a first step for
workers now they have to try to
negotiate and win concessions from some
of the richest and most powerful
companies in the world
patty calhane al jazeera washington